good morning millennials
welcome back to the chosen happy Monday
hope everybody's having a gorgeous start
to their work hey gorgeous hiya darn I'm
darn good excited to be back on the
toast but boy have I had a weekend have
I had a morning what happened to you my
sweet angel Harry has been sick all
weekend and we were coming out the other
end you know we we made do it's just
it's just hard because of Charlie like
keeping them apart whatever Harry has I
don't want Charlie to get so this
morning I called the doctor to get Harry
to see the doctor and of course like
what time could she do toast time oh so
it's just been hectic here to say the
least just know when I find the person
who infected our little Herald with
whatever sort of illness
just now
just know you know yeah
just no yeah so it was a stressful
weekend like we were literally cordoned
off Zach and Harry in one room watching
Mickey Mouse Mickey as Harry calls it
and then me and Charlie in the other
room so it was just that was like kind
of sad for the weekend I made a huge pot
of soup for the house
which no one ate except for me
I mean soup like I stand with the kids
here because I have like a very you know
limited palette I'm a picky eater much
like that of a child even though Harry
eats definitely like more complex things
than me
um and I stand with the kids like when
you're sick and someone's like soup
off well when even though made it with
her heart and soul because he got sick
on Saturday morning and the kosher
restaurants aren't open to like you know
I'm not really in my home making mode
right now I would have just ordered soup
but he needed kosher soup and it was
Saturday everything was closed so mama
got to chopping no for sure and you're
gonna eat my soup and you're gonna like
it let me tell you the annoying thing
about soup when you're sick like that
does make you feel better like they
call it the Jewish penicillin for a
reason like there is medicinal qualities
but my God like one even when I'm not
sick but more so when I'm sick like the
thought of drinking that broth like I
actually I actually disagree with you
that's okay the few times I've been sick
this year all I've wanted was soup and
bread even when I had my circles but
course even when I had my sir collages
and I was like recovering all I wanted
was soup like mom kept bringing me soup
and that was literally the only thing
that sounded good because it's like you
only kind of want to drink stuff but you
also need sustenance AKA soup what if I
just had a soup let me tell you what
I'll say let's I'll end with this okay
okay
soup with bread greater than just soup
for sure but mama's offering bread I got
fresh challah of course of course of
course I just saw I thought it was
important to mention you didn't even
want challah so I could really can't
take it personally
wow also on the topic of challah and
soup it is important to note we are
entering like the Jewish holiday era now
this weekend is the start of the Jewish
New Year it is Rosh Hashanah which is a
pretty good holiday and we'll be
together family friends Fun and Sun you
know what's better than that but I'd be
remiss I would be devastated I might
even be heartbroken if I didn't at least
mention that what comes after Rosh
Hashanah if you've been following the
show for a while now you know even if
you've never met a Jew in your life you
know what comes next because we talk
about it every year and actually every
day yeah every day I think about how
much time I have left until the dreaded
Yom Kippur it is our day of atonement it
is the saddest day in the Jewish
calendar it is a day of fasting which
means for 25 hours your girls can't eat
and it's approaching it's it's what the
first week of October I believe so just
know that that's coming that if we seem
kind of on edge in the coming weeks
that's why and I'm not looking I for one
I'm not looking forward to it I think
it's actually sooner than the first week
of October yeah it's octo it's September
25th just so that you can prepare
yourself
and I know what you guys are thinking oh
my God another Jewish holiday these
girls are going to be off there's no
show yes there's no show September 25th
but just know we're not happy about it
no usually when we have a day off it's
like oh what are we doing where are we
going what are we seeing what do we know
this time of year a day off is a scary
thing because it could be Yom Kippur
like working day greater than fasting
day you said it sister you said it also
I'm fairly certain that even though Rosh
Hashanah is upcoming it actually will
not affect our listeners whatsoever
because it falls on a weekend it's two
days we usually take the one day because
we have to it's a very high holiday uh
but it's on the weekend so really for
our grayish listeners your life is
unchanged yeah that's true but back in
the day when we went to school we of
course went to Jewish Day School like
Rosh Hashanah falling on a uh weekend
like a worse thing couldn't happen to a
12 year old like it was just unfair it
was brutal but this year you know I'm a
business owner I'm feeling great full
that it falls on the weekend because it
doesn't affect our business yeah the
show Will Go On
yes and oh my God it's just like it's an
app setting and how close we are to Yom
Kippur like I really need to start
preparing myself
yeah well I fasted recently so I'm
feeling like I can do it
I feel like I'm going to answer a common
question I might get as somebody who's
on ozemping literally cheater cheater
pumpkin eater first of all done
listening to you completely about Yom
Kippur what if you have the appetite of
a breastfeeding mama okay well you don't
actually you could probably find a buck
look at to get you out of it since
you're breastfeeding I know I haven't
spoken to a rabbi about you know the
effects but let me just say I'm sure
people are wondering well girl you're on
ozembic you're not hungry let me tell
you how hunger still strikes when you're
Ono's epic the same
um the same you know frequency in which
it would if you were not on ozembic it
just would take less food to keep you
full now I have to imagine of course I'm
not stupid it will be easier of course I
was on it last year though yeah and you
were fine I remember was I you were fine
I imagine that that's how other normal
people who have normal like
relationships with food I imagine that's
how they experience young people because
it was still a struggle but in recent
years like not on ozempic when I've had
to fast it's literally like so
impossible that that can't be normal the
way no one is listening to you
complaining about Yom Kippur anymore
namely me you know if we have any
rabbinical students or rabbis themselves
or wives of rabbis who are listening
what is like the law you shouldn't be
able to shoot up that week
well what day of the week is Yom Kippur
Monday
okay actually my daily you know my
weekly shot I get on Wednesdays and by
the time Monday Tuesday rolls around
like I it does start to wear off and I
am feeling hungry so to be honest it's
not going to help me that much if if Yom
Kippur was on like a Friday when it's
Peak shot oh easy peasy
wait Friday is two days before
no I take my shots on Wednesdays oh okay
and by Friday it's like at its highest
peak Peak understood yes understood like
Fridays you're not gonna catch me like
having a cheat day Fridays are like my
day
got it well
I just I wanted to be open and honest
about that I had to bring it up yeah no
I'm glad that you did because here I was
indulging you in your annual Yom Kippur
talk yep and no nope putting the kebash
let me tell you I don't even feel bad
like I I do I'm doing what I gotta do to
survive yeah no do what you gotta do
but us listeners of you just grain of
salt
grain of salt you know what I will take
that
yes okay so if anybody wants like a
little lesson in Jewish theology a kazai
it's rough Trends actually not rough
it's actual translation ziet is Olive
and when you put Ka in front of it it's
like the word kamo shortened kamo means
like so kezai like an olive so the rule
actually historically on Yom Kippur is I
think you're feeling like faint you're
feeling like you can't go on like you it
will affect your health if you don't
need something it is totally legal to
have a kazai something like an olive
like this size so in recent years when
I've needed a kazai an m m is a gorgeous
Keziah it's actually you could have two
maybe three because size wise what kind
of olive are we talking about no and
it's like this is where the rabbis would
do their thing and discuss until the
ends of the Earth it's like could I have
multiple cazades or right like is each
bite it has to be a small bite but like
they didn't say just one what did they
mean by that and that's there's text
upon texts about that yeah that's like
so Jewish like interpreting language and
manipulating it until it fits your needs
yeah but speaking of like an olive
Lauren Elizabeth had her baby named
Olive so did stassi and stassi had a
baby and so now if Lauren Elizabeth
would like a Hebrew name for her baby
girl might I suggest zait it's kind of
gorgeous or because I eat like an olive
I definitely think the Lutheran housing
name has Jewish like history somewhere
in there I know I believe that it does I
think she's told us that yeah so zayat
Zai Lutheran housing
and I know Lauren's listening to this
episode like while feeding her child so
hey girlie hope you're doing well hope
you're doing well very excited for her
you know what let's not sing a lot Lord
hope all the mamas who are listening to
this episode rearing children at
whatever stage are doing well because
it's the world's toughest job it really
is speaking of mamas so the content hole
that I've fallen down still is Molly May
and Tommy Fury and I finished love
Island season five since we last spoke
you guys the ending was just
what jarring whatever whatever they gave
us Tommy and Molly and that's what's
important 100 so now I'm watching Molly
Mae's Vlogs and as a new a recent new
mom I was watching her like postpartum
Vlogs like her birth story and then she
vlogged like two months later just about
like being a mom and the way I just felt
so seen by this girl oh it was so nice
she was so open I really didn't expect
her to really be talking about some some
of the nitty-gritty uh Jack's burst I
feel I think that's how some people feel
about you like you really are a warrior
well I feel like watching her made me
feel like I'm not that open and it's
really nice when someone is
but you really are especially like on
patreon and stuff like you go there yeah
once the topic comes up I guess on this
show like we don't we don't talk about
just postpartum Tings but if I like sat
down and made a video like Molly did
yeah I would I did my birth story she
did her birth story and I just I love
watching that sort of content so it made
me want to just share more if anybody
wants to hear anything I want to hear
how's your mucus plug
I think she talked about her music her
mucus plug Queen wow she said it did it
fall out it flew out she said no she
probably said it flew out it flew all
the way out and the way I'm gonna start
speaking with an accent now because
that's all I watch I know I also watched
at home with the furies which is the
reason why I started all this you know
the fury family got a reality show on
Netflix yeah it's Tyson Tommy's big
brother who's a heavyweight champion I
didn't know him
and his family life's really interesting
but but really the glimpses of Tommy and
Molly are really interesting of course
and they're very interesting family to
have a reality show but I don't think
the show was very well done it's
extremely repetitive in terms of like
what everyone is saying well I think
we're going to start seeing a lot of
random unscripted reality shows all over
the streaming services because it's kind
of the only type of project that's
sanctioned in the SAG strikes so it's
the strike is really like draw it's it's
been a long time and I don't really see
an end in sight so I do think that's the
type of content we're going to be seeing
one I'm here for it that's the kind of
content I can wrap my head around right
now two it's been a long time that
they've been on strike but not a long
time since Labor Day I don't think
anything I don't think anything was
happening before Labor Day so it's like
it's almost as if it's like week one of
the strike in terms of resolution I
agree but then I also heard you know
from somebody who's like smart and a
different person who told me that it
would end in September said most likely
now January
wow yeah so expect to see a lot of
stand-up specials and a lot of reality
TV I have been seeing stand up I happen
to stand up now that I think about it I
think if you're a comedian who's been
trying to sell your special like like
Claudia yeah I'm having no luck but if
you are not me I think this might be
your chance like if you see people
getting like big specials on Netflix or
any streaming service that you might not
have pegged for like you know Netflix's
type I think that's I think that's why I
have no proof of that it's just a
thought I had it makes it also also I
didn't choose this as a story but are
you seeing all this Jessica Chastain
Venice Film Festival drama no not a
thing so Jessica chassis at Venice Film
Festival promoting like this movie that
she did and it's not like a big budget
movie studio because you know Venice
Film Festival it's like very it's not
independent but it's like always smaller
budget and it's a sag sanctioned press
tour that she's on I think it sag said
it's good it helps filmmakers I'm not
entirely sure but it's caused like a lot
of controversy and then Amy Schumer
posted a picture
um it was like a Paparazzi photo of her
at the US Open looking like a little not
disgruntled but like you know she was
making a face like
and she captioned it like when I see
celebrities promoting their films at the
Venice Film Festival because there have
been like a few and they're all
sanctioned they're not considered
crossing the picket line but I think
it's a controversial
thing well it just seems a little pick
and choose it does and it seems a little
unscrupled oh it's that like sag just
gets to decide who gets to promote their
films and of course I'm sure there's
people who have interest in the Venice
film festival and if really no
celebrities are promoting it then like
the Venice Film Festival is gonna
tank and no it's not really so much
promoting the film festival it's
promoting the people whose films are in
the film festival and they're not backed
by like major Studios and they are these
sort of like more independent filmmakers
and people who sag wants to lift up
Jessica Chastain like has been in her
comments fighting for her life
responding and she's you know she's
making sense it's just kind of you know
like the celebrities are fighting no
that's really crazy but it just sort of
feels and by the way I don't know enough
about the whole thing to say like who's
right and who's wrong but it's just been
really interesting no yeah I don't know
enough either but it just kind of
reminds me of how like you know they
promoted Barbie and Oppenheimer like to
death and then they decided and now
we're done and now nobody can promote
anything ever again the strike had not
begun yes it had no it hadn't the
writers strike did but then sag in
solidarity hadn't started yet right that
didn't start until Barbie you know spent
their last dollar of the 100 million
dollar
yes it was convenient timing it was the
biggest film of the year right right
that's what I'm saying yeah so
Thanksgiving willy-nilly
[Laughter]
Willy Miller not willy-nilly I'm also
jazzed not jazzed that's probably not
the right word but I'm also very into
the stories today
and I am falling down a crazy Rabbit
Hole of Ashton Kutcher Mila Kunis like
it's wild what's going on okay and I'll
explain it you explain the ins and outs
because I'm just like
I've got the headlines you know that's I
haven't I've got the subtext no I want
to know but I also want you to know what
I think is someone who's just like a
little zoomed out from the situation
yeah yeah no I'm definitely not zoomed
out and I have a lot of thoughts also I
think we'd be remiss if we didn't
acknowledge that today is 9 11.
always a very tough day especially in
New York and it's just so weird that
it's just like a day you know yeah like
people like get married because it's
just a day like people's birthdays are
today and there are also people like are
some maybe even some of our peers who
weren't even born
I'm so crazy to think about I was
thinking about that this morning Shannon
posted a really nice set of stories
about 9 11 and she was saying if you're
younger than 22 you weren't alive for it
which is wild to me I mean it is but we
were also so young I was in the first
grade yeah I was in
I might have been in the second grade
actually no I think I was in second
grade
no I was in the first grade
were you one oh yeah no you're two years
below me I was not in the third grade
you were
actually I think I was in the second
grade and you were in the fourth that
makes sense I know it's an even number
yes so but it just goes to show like
I've always known exactly like where I
was on 9 11 but now like the details
start to fade I know and we need to like
we need to not because we need to always
I feel like there's so many people
walking around now who aren't even alive
it doesn't like impact them in the way
that it impacts people who were there
and it's just so everyone should watch
United 93 that's like probably one of my
favorite
it's really a tough watch it's like
probably the saddest movie I've ever
seen in my life yeah but you get some
Peter Hermann oh is he in it I everyone
who's in that movie like I know it
wasn't like a big budget it wasn't a big
movie like um Money Maker for them I
just think it was like a story everyone
wanted to tell so anyone who's in that
movie like I have deep respect and
admiration for yeah but that's also the
sort of movie I can only watch Once
agreed
like if it's on TV Skip it's so painful
yeah like not a good happy ending you
need to know the story but it's not
something that I'm just gonna like watch
and re-watch right and it's like one of
the stories of 911 that's not like the
biggest story of course like we always
are hearing about the towers and stories
from amazing like heroic people and
United 93 is just kind of like a smaller
story and and the fact that it's a movie
I think I just have a lot of people
learned about that flight that almost
hit the Pentagon right yeah yeah and
it's just it's a tough day so I wanted
to acknowledge it thank you I'm glad
that you did I was thinking the same
thing
um just like Eerie vibe in New York you
know yeah it's it's a somber day it is
and there's no getting around it you
know yeah no it it comes everywhere it
just is and you just have to sit with it
yeah I've actually never been to the 911
memorial have you
no I've never been through the like
experience me neither I think I should
go yeah I've heard it's amazing yeah
well sorry to you know damper but wanted
to acknowledge yes thank you very much
and I think perhaps it's time
Perhaps it is time to dive into the fast
five stories that you need to know
so true by the way that you definitely
need to know and the fast five stories
that you need to know are brought to you
by the MTV Video Music Awards so the MTV
video music awards are music's most
iconic Night Live tomorrow at eight not
me thinking they were last night
literally getting all set up on TV I'm
like Ben we're gonna watch it and it's
Tuesday my bad it's tomorrow at 8pm
there are live performances from artists
like Lil Wayne stray kids and more Demi
Lovato is returning after six years for
a performance that's sure to bring the
house down nobody nobody's vocals try as
they may are as powerful as Demi Lovato
honestly and everyone's talking about
this year's video Vanguard award Shakira
is giving a career spanning performance
Shakira Shakira Shakira very deserving
of this award I feel like she's kind of
been in her stride like of getting those
kind of Lifetime moments and now getting
video of Vanguard is huge
um and the global icon Diddy is also
taking the stage I feel like he's going
to bring people out I feel like that's
going to be iconic so uh everyone's
talking about that everyone's also
talking about who's going to take home
video of the year will it be knowja cat
Miley Cyrus Nicki Minaj Olivia Rodrigo
Sam Smith Kim Petrus scissa Taylor Swift
now of course everybody's just talking
about like what's going to happen at the
VMAs me specifically I've been on social
media everybody's theorizing we just got
to tune in and see I think it's going to
be a great night of music so it's live
tomorrow at 8 it's the MTV Video Music
Awards you do not want to miss it I will
be watching we'll probably be recapping
it I'm sure there'll be a ton of stories
that come out after you know hobnob and
celebs everyone's and also it's a
fabulous time to be in New York because
everybody's in New York now for the VMAs
so Video Music Awards on MTV live
tomorrow at eight o'clock today's
episode is also brought to you by
Caraway caraway's non-stick kitchenware
makes cooking a breeze and clean up
easier than ever it's back to school
made easy with so many collections of
their internet famous kitchen where to
explore there's a Caraway for every kind
of cook it's a non-toxic chemical free
ceramic coating that means that your
foods can be prepared with peace of mind
that no hard to pronounce chemicals will
leach into your healthy ingredients
every set comes in a variety of modern
Shades to fit with any design aesthetic
and it includes easy access storage
solutions to keep your kitchen tidy
so Jax I know you're a big Caraway girl
how does it feel to be home like with
your full Caraway set with my calorie
set in my favorite color the cream set
it feels great and my chicken soup this
weekend was brought to you by Caraway
and honestly I wasn't like great about
the temperature like I left it simmering
all afternoon like fell asleep
um and I think in any other pot it would
have burned for sure and instead curry
made it nice and crispy and when I went
to clean up nothing stuck per usual it
was so amazing and I also used their
stowaway takeaway containers
um oh yeah to store my soup I had two
huge ones so I put one in the fridge and
one in the freezer because it's the best
way to do food storage and it looks so
nice and also makes your food look
appetizing because sometimes leftovers
like Tupperware plastic Tupperware like
I don't want to go near that but when
it's in my ceramic Airway yum no and
when you're cooking for a a roldini on
the mend only the best only Caraway only
the best for mommy's Angels visit
carawayhome.com
toast10 to take advantage of this
limited time offer for 10 off your next
purchase the deal is exclusive for
toasters so visit carawayhome.com
toast10 or just use code toast 10 at
checkout Caraway non-toxic cookware made
Modern honestly they have a set of pink
pots and pans that I keep getting
targeted ads for that I kind of try to
get yeah and I'm going to use toast 10.
as you should yeah our first story
Ashton Kutcher and Mino acunis address
the pain caused by their letter about
Danny Masterson they said we support
victims so Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis
say they're sorry for any pain or trauma
caused by the character letters they
wrote for their That 70s Show co-star
Danny Masterson who was sentenced on
Thursday to 30 years to life in prison
for raping two women in a video posted
Saturday on Kutcher's Instagram account
they addressed how the letters which
were obtained Friday by The Hollywood
Reporter came about they said that
Danny's Family approached them after the
actor's conviction in May and asked them
to write character letters representing
the person that we knew for 25 years
Ashton said Mila said the letters were
not written to question the legitimacy
of the judicial system or the validity
of the jury's ruling we support victims
we have done this historically through
work and will continue to do so in the
future they were intended for the judge
to read and not to undermine the
testimony of the victims or to
re-traumatize them in any way we would
never want to do that and we're sorry if
that has taken place
okay
so this was a crazy Saga now from the
beginning Jenny Masterson from that 70
shows was convicted uh of drugging and
raping two women
he was sentenced to 30 years in prison
and like Ashton emila said was those
letters were written not to uh get him
the jury or the conviction but just to
uh take into consideration when
sentencing him I think they thought that
they were going to be private because
they were just read for the judge enough
for anyone else they were not private
um in your research have you seen
whether or not like they were how they
were leaked
they weren't leaked it's public
information it wasn't yes and I wrote it
down it's worth mentioning that uh they
were not the only celebrities that wrote
letters for ash for Danny Masterson
they're obviously the most famous but
Deborah Joe Rupp who plays the mom in
That 70s Show that little old lady she
wrote One Giovanni robisi who you would
know from Ted as fresh cakes
yes and the lesser-known Baldwin brother
William Baldwin got it well fresh cake
Sky writing a character letter like just
given his character in Ted I just
assumed if that happens
now everybody is you know this is kind
of like a an ethical dilemma people are
debating like
was it the right thing was it the wrong
thing they're his friend yada yada now
personally my take is like vomit I would
literally never like this is this is
like actually embarrassing for Mila
Kunis and Ashton Kutcher I don't care
how close you are with someone like the
crimes he's not even accused convicted
of are so abhorrent plus the other layer
here that I think is causing people to
spiral and conspiracy theorize is Danny
Masterson
is a Scientologist and Scientology this
these crimes happened a long time ago
Scientology was very involved in
covering up these crimes for Danny
Masterson so now everyone's like this is
so off brand for Mila Kunis and Ashton
Kutcher they have a non-profit called
Thorn they're very very active in human
trafficking and sexual abuse crimes like
they are so active in the sense of sorry
in the sense of trying to help eliminate
and help of victims of sexual sex crimes
it's so off brand for them it's so
bizarre Mila Kunis's last film is the
luckiest girl alive which is about a sex
crime like it just makes no sense now of
course the element of Scientology has
led people to
theorize
and an Instagram story
from one of Danny Masterson's
ex-girlfriends has really caused the
rabbit hole of people you know making up
theories to
be blown open okay an ex-girlfriend or
is it one of the accusers
both
she's okay okay
so they had released that video which we
should talk about because it was just
bizarre like
it yeah okay so Danny Masterson's
accuser and I'm citing uh one of the
places that I've been watching a lot of
videos is this girl on Tick Tock who I
love the talk of Shame she does like a
good job recapping and you know who's
who in all of this
um her name is Chrissy Bixler she's an
ex-girlfriend and an accuser of Danny
Masterson and she had posted this story
uh once Milan Ashton had posted their
video which was incredibly bizarre
um
let me find it sorry just give me two
seconds
I was just watching this video before
the toast
just it's important hold on
here
okay so she wrote on her Instagram story
dear Ashton I know the secrets you're
quote role model keeps for you ones that
would end you did you forget I was there
you were on speakerphone that night you
called Danny on February 21st 2011. I
heard everything I heard the plan in my
opinion you're just as sick as your
Mentor so now what happened February
21st 2001. I'll tell you what happened a
girl that Ashton Kutcher was dating was
found dead stabbed 47 times in her home
now Ashton Kutcher actually was
a witness on the trial and he had said
that he came to pick her up for a date
looked through the window saw red wine
all over the floor he said what he
thought was red wine
and
left
that's his involvement but Chrissy
Bixler is saying I heard you call I
heard the plan he had called Danny now a
friend of Chrissy Bixler who's now a
podcaster and it's like you know
releasing content had said Ashton
actually called Danny and said he went
to the door opened the door saw her her
dead went back in his car and called his
team his agents his lawyers Danny
Masterson and you know concocted some
sort of alleged plan for you know he
didn't want to
be you know you call you call someone
like hey there's a dead body you're
obviously going to be the first suspect
so he had called a bunch of people and
came up with this sort of plan I believe
that that's what the internet is now
believing Chrissy Bixler to have meant
because a friend of hers went on a
podcast and said that that was what the
conversation with Danny Masterson was
and that's what happened the night of
February 21st 2011. then Chrissy Bixler
also addressed Mila and said dear Mila I
pray you begin to process what you
experience as a child on that set your
old interviews are very telling I
encourage everyone to watch them and
decide for yourself what you hear and
what you see
do so before they get scrubbed from the
internet I also know what happened in
Toronto and after question if that's
what you're if that's what you view hold
on let me clear display if that's what
you view as a normal relationship with a
big brother figure then I feel very sad
for you and I hope you consider getting
into therapy you almost forget I was
there the whole time those first five
years after That 70s Show I remember
everything I'm not entirely sure what
the Mila part is and I think that's
something the internet is still sort of
digesting but it's a lot
yeah that's a lot and it definitely
takes you down a rabbit hole of other
things in terms of the letter and the
apology though yeah the apology video
the apology video was was bad bad and
I've never been in the position of you
know
what their what the position that they
were in when they wrote the letter they
know this guy or think they know this
person for 25 years they're advocating
for a more lenient sentence than
probably what he got because he got a
very Hefty sentence he did they really
made an example out of him which is
fabulous right so
they did what what they thought they
should do given the situation and given
their you know obvious sensitivity and
support for victims you know like I
don't think you can deny that so that
and they chose to write that letter and
that's what they thought what the right
thing to do was and obviously they got a
lot of heat for it I
I think that this apology fixes nothing
and actually only makes it worse and
makes them look incredibly unscrupled at
least and
they should have if it would be I never
would have written the letter like I
just think that was the wrong choice for
them too okay but they made a lot of
choice a lot of people are now like
speculating that because Scientology is
involved and because there's like this
Litany of like things I just read it's
entirely possible that like they were
blackmailed or like you know hostage
because everyone's like it looks like a
hostage video the apology looks like
hostile yes but they were like coerced
into writing those letters that's what a
lot of people think just because
Scientology now makes everyone
suspicious of everything right the fact
Ashton and Mila are not scientologists
no but Scientology being a factor in
this case makes everyone just now look
at everything suspiciously
okay but I think to what you were saying
okay so they decided to write the
letters that's what they thought was the
right thing to do I think they cited you
know Danny's daughter as one of the main
reasons for that
they if they were gonna do that then
they never should have explained
themselves because this video helped
nobody did nothing at least if they
never explained themselves there's like
an air of mystery to it where we're like
well we could never understand but now
I'm like um that was the wrong call yeah
I don't think anybody who was mad at
them for writing the letter has forgiven
them in their apology so no and it just
makes them look like
weak willy-nilly honestly willy-nilly
everyone family asked for a letter they
write a letter internet says for apology
they write an apology what do you stand
for is this man really your friend and
you really think that he's a good man of
good character then stand for that no
you're so right it's very it's getting
spineless
[Laughter]
and um of course now everyone is
dissecting every millisecond of the
video they both keep looking to the
right it appears that they have some
sort of computer there because you can
also hear a click which is crazy yeah
it's clear that they're reading
something which doesn't bother me
because if you're saying something
important like I do want you to get it
right you know this isn't a memorization
test like if you want and you know
you're always asking for people to put
their face in front of the camera
they're apologizing so like that's fine
by me but it's just like the tone of it
the setting yeah and the content
and now we're in that cycle of you're on
the chopping block we're gonna look into
everything you've ever done right so old
interviews that are actually
weird and like are
Beyond inappropriate are especially
given Mila Kunis's age when she started
that 70 show which was 14. she said she
had her first kiss on set and it was
actually with Ashton and so I think
people used to look at that and be like
oh that's so cute they ended up getting
married and he was her first kiss but
they were on I forget what show it was
it might have been Conan like one of the
an old a show and he they were talking
about their first kiss and they were
like
just telling this story and the more
they told it like this is really
weird she was 14. everyone's a tea 19.
everybody knew that it was like going to
be her first kiss ever when they were
filming it and Danny Masterson like
paid or bet Ashton Kutcher like some
money to like stick his tongue in her
mouth because you know it's a TV sitcom
kiss it's just supposed to be like lips
um but he like you know they tried to
make it funny
and that was like Mila Kunis's first
kiss and it was just like people cited
it as a you know a pattern with Danny
Masterson being creepy 20 years
ago and now even more
um
but so now they're in that cycle of like
internet culture where everything that
they've ever done and said is coming out
just to kind of prove a pattern of bad
behavior and I will say it was
compelling
yeah no that's it it's
less bad since they're married and
obviously she liked him and right
whatever but it you know you could put a
bow in it but then when you go back and
look at everything under a microscope
yeah everything looks bad this is just
crazy because these are two celebrities
who throughout their career have been
almost Untouched by Scandal yeah and so
well liked by their peers by America by
Hollywood like they are we're just kind
of living in this golden
situation yeah and this is something
that neither of them really have
experience with and it's interesting
because now all these things are coming
to light but when they had come to light
there wasn't crazy everyone's now you
know also citing Demi Moore's book her
Memoir where she says that Ashton
Kutcher kind of forced her into doing
like things she was uncomfortable with
like threesomes and when that came out
like there wasn't some campaign they've
really just kind of been golden yeah
also they're so successful that I
sometimes think like when you reach a
level of success like you're kind of
immune to cancellation because
Untouchable you have like businesses
that will Thrive with or without you
like your money's coming in so it
doesn't really matter what the backlash
is or what people on Twitter are saying
about you but I don't know if this is
really affecting them or they just care
so much about their Public Image
personas that they felt the need to
apologize
above you know the the public apology
public apology no the video
was a mistake I think of course writing
the letters were a mistake but I think
that's a conversation people can go back
and forth on like if you love someone
actually weirdly enough Kathy Griffin uh
so many celebrities have come out and
given given their thoughts Topher Grace
who was also on That 70s Show him and
his wife were like
totally like making content posting
content standing with the victims making
it clear that they did not think that
was the right choice for Ashton Mila
Christina Ricci did the same thing but
Kathy Griffin made a video that I
thought was really interesting
um that I didn't know about her she said
a lot of people might not know this but
my brother was a pedophile
he you know molested young kids
um and Kathy Griffin called the police
on him many times and and wanted him to
get caught he's no longer alive and I
think that's why she feels comfortable
talking about it but she was citing her
experience like knowing someone you love
is capable of doing very
disturbing disgusting criminal things is
definitely a conflict and she said in my
experience like I didn't even think
twice about
protecting people from my brother I
called the police on my brother so that
was her her example for something she
went through that was similar so I don't
think I would have done what they did
but they did it and to do it and then
like kind of reneg and make a video that
appeases nobody it's a very bizarre
strategy yeah
yeah
so and like it's so hard to get a rape
conviction because it's you need like a
a lot of evidence
um so the fact that they got it and then
it was like trying attempting to be
diminished and I know that's what they
thought they said that's not what they
were doing but it does is just I don't
know how you can have like a literal
non-profit organization your whole
life's work they don't really they're
not working actors anymore I think they
wake up every day and they work on Thorn
which is their their yeah or like he's
he's an investor and he has business
right so like he's a man I don't really
understand how you could in good
conscience write those letters when for
the last several years like your work
has been to help victims right which is
why you have to consider like how they
felt like how they knew him and how they
felt about him that they felt compelled
to do that because I don't think it was
just like a whatever decision we'll
write this letter for this person who
did terrible things like I think that's
what they're trying to say in their
video like yeah I think if you look at
it through the lens of them being forced
and perhaps blackmailed which I know
sounds crazy it does make a lot more
sense it makes it easier to digest yeah
but I think that the Dynamics at play
here are a lot more complicated than
that like that makes it oh okay now it
all makes sense you know bad versus good
right we understand but it's so true
that they're struggling with all these
different emotions and they were asked
to write a character letter about the
person that they knew
who they clearly loved was a big part of
their lives enough to do that and
they're you know while also having the
utmost sympathy and respect for victims
because that is their life's work right
I think it was a complicated Dynamic and
that's the decision that they ended up
making not the same decision probably a
lot of people would make right but I
think there were a lot of things that
went into it but yeah if you want to
think of it as blackmail it makes it a
lot more easy it just makes it just it's
one plus one equals two whereas this
case it's giving one plus one equals
sock yeah
very interesting Saga with two
celebrities that have really never been
through it like this yeah and I think
they're making matters worse for
themselves no they're inexperiences
showing
yeah for sure because I think this news
cycle would have
washed it out
if they if we never heard from them we
could have really chucked it up there
would have been like an air of mystery
to it being like well it's a tough spot
to be in you know we could have just
said it would guess it would be added to
the list of things it's like one day
whenever their time came it would be
like and they wrote letters for Danny
Masterson yeah but no now like hearing
their explanation which really was not
sufficient or clear no it's made matters
worse it would have behooved them to
stay silent like I'm assuming all the
other celebrities who are far less
famous who wrote letters are going to do
yeah they're just gonna hide behind Mila
and Ashton no you guys for sure this one
we have enough money
no you can withstand it some of us can't
yeah no some of them can't yeah very but
you know at the end of the day I think
now everyone's talking about Mila and
Ashton what I think a lot of people are
like breezing past is he's been
sentenced to 30 years in prison which is
in my opinion an appropriate sentencing
I think a lot of people are like it's
really harsh but it's not right so the
justice has been served right I guess
the letters weren't compelling enough
right
sometimes you gotta let the wheels of
Justice turn dude it's so true
are you ready for our next story
I am
Kylie Jenner and Timothy chalamet get
touchy-feely during a date at the U.S
Open tennis file final so the US Open
made news this weekend obviously we have
new Champions
Djokovic Coco goth we'll talk about the
tennis but we also have to talk about
the celebs and the headline is Kylie and
Timothy like took their relationship out
for a spin and they're smitten with each
other they are they've just kind of been
like out and about in New York and they
haven't been like posting together but
you know Fashion Week is full of cameras
social media and we've gotten a few like
things of them they went to a dinner
together
um they went shopping together Jordan
Woods was yeah that was story two subset
B
it's kind of like been a busy week for
Kylie there's a lot to dissect let's
start with just like the videos of them
and how they interact as a couple it's
extremely cute like you would never
catch me standing before like I just I
couldn't visualize it but now it's been
visualized for me and I'm into it yes I
agree visually they look nice they look
so happy and in love and she's never I
guess she was that way with Tyga
actually very public with him into him
you know he was on the show and on the
trips and I'm sure Travis Scott was just
like a more private person so we didn't
really they did like red carpets but we
didn't really get this yeah and she's
obviously feeling very confident in
their relationship just putting it all
on display for us it's just so funny how
like the Kardashian girls like seem to
date the same same type of men at the
same time because like
p uh what's his name Timothy chalamet
like definitely gives Pete Davidson
energy definitely gives a Travis sparker
energy like really skinny I find it
funny that like they're they're tasting
men is changing yeah
like it's actually yeah no it is and
they all really give the same energy and
Kylie looks really happy she's been so
um like touchy like at the Beyonce
concert they're like they look like a
regular couple like just like a PDA
couple yeah but like extra gorgeous no
of course not just any please and still
like Timothy is not like my dream man
but Kylie is making me find favor with
him I know I'm definitely looking at him
like this now like oh
differently a little differently yeah so
a little different it looks like they
have fun plus you know we have new
winners US Open has come to a close it
was a very fabulous week turdy Lou was
spotted I was open amongst other celebs
thank you how was your experience there
it was great
um so many celebrities especially like
these last two days because those were
like the last couple of matches Leonardo
DiCaprio Amanda Seyfried Cara deleving
like really everyone Kylie
and Matthew McConaughey Matthew
McConaughey was weirdly in Novak
djokovic's box so what he won like
everybody runs up to their box and like
hugs their family and like literally
before he hugged his wife he hugged
Matthew McConaughey and his wife like it
was kind of crazy cute cute friendship
yeah like it was just unexpected yeah
who were you rooting for
well the thing is neither one of them
are Americans so like whatever you know
I don't have like a stake in this game
like with Coco goth of course the other
girl was Belarusian so I wanted the
American to win
um
I don't I don't really know these two
men so initially I'm like oh no back's
the goat like of course we're gonna be
rooting for Novak but he was the other
guy was like losing so bad and like the
crowd wasn't with him and I've seen some
videos of him on social media he gives
like Peach on energy like I'm an empath
I started to feel for him like come on
Medvedev like get it together at the end
I really had no horse in this race so
the greater man won and you know we are
living we are watching one of the greats
and he's setting new records it was his
24th title he is the oldest person to
win a title like that so I love to see
people making history when he won he
honored his friend I didn't even know
they were friends the late Kobe Bryant
with he changed his T-shirt put on Mamba
forever because it was his 24th win and
24 was Kobe so it was nice I was happy
with how it ended that's very nice I
can't like I didn't watch one second of
the US Open you really missed out it was
fabulous people watching I'm sure I
don't know I just I was never drawn to
it and I just missed it but you know
what I was thinking because I've been
watching all this Fieri family content
and it's like the way I wish I was alive
for the Tommy Fury Jake Paul fight six
months ago which I was like that's a uh
thing that like I totally missed but I
was alive and present could have watched
it yep maybe that's how I feel about the
US Open in a few months after I watched
the Novak documentary actually there is
a documentary on Netflix called match
point I haven't watched it but it's
about like the life of a pro tennis
player and is it better than the movie
match point no definitely not but at
that point is one of the world's
greatest gifts movie Match Point greater
than documentary match point you said it
there sister you said it there yeah so
now I'm ready I think Tommy has a fight
in a few weeks so like I'll definitely
be watching yeah you gotta get that
pay-per-view can you order pay-per-view
on YouTube TV I think they're totally
separate like pay-per-view is an app no
no it's a channel
I'm sure it'll be streaming somewhere
I'm sure that if I want to buy it they
will take my money and find me actually
they make it really hard to like
spend your money when you want to watch
pay-per-view actually I'm kind of
dealing with a with an issue with my
cable company right now because there
was a Jake Paul fight last month we had
like some people over so I was like oh
let me buy it 60 bucks first of all they
charged me twice so I get my bill this
month I'm like oh excuse me I just
submit a ticket it was like a whole
thing they'd call me I got my money back
but you I like I think you have to have
cable it's pay-per-view like that's it's
like an old school thing perhaps did
Jake Paul win
his fight that you watched I fell asleep
before Jake they have like a whole
lineup there's like girl fights and then
smaller guys like right there's like a
whole lineup and I got bored I don't
remember well now I also I like Jake
Paul fights too because I watched Untold
Jake Paul the problem child so
I'm really just into boxing now and I'll
be watching these going forward it's
like a fun thing when there was a fight
on because like especially if it's a
fight that everyone's talking about like
you invite everyone over and like you
have snacks it's kind of like the Super
Bowl like I just can't imagine there
ever being like a boxing fight more
culturally relevant in my sphere Than
Jake Paul and Tommy Fury and you missed
it and I missed it but just know
like when when the time comes for you to
watch your next fight like the main
event like doesn't start till midnight
okay good to know but also now having
watched more content of you know Tyson
and Tommy sometimes these things turn
into like a saga like a Trilogy and I
think Tommy and Jake would rematch I
could see Jake challenging him to a
rematch well Tommy won yeah so Tommy's
probably happy like maybe never doing it
again but Jake is like now I want
some more right but also it's like for
The Vibes and also if you want to be the
best you've got to beat the best so I
don't think Tommy would shy away from
anything and I think you make a lot of
money especially when you're fighting
Jake Paul who brings in so many viewers
you do make a lot of money now can we
really quickly go back to subset B of
Kylie and Jordan yes Kylie and Jordan
reunited they were spotted together at
the acne
um Studio store Kylie's the new face of
acne Studios and Kylie posted a tick
tock including Jordan
so this is like the second or third time
that the girl is have been Girling and I
think it's you know abundantly clear
that they've made up and I'm so here for
the reunion like because this was a
great friendship I just like have a hard
time
like really truly
getting into the mindset like I feel
like if I was Jordan yeah I could never
be friends with Kylie again even though
like of course Jordan like made the
mistake she kissed Tristan whatever but
like the Fallout was so insane and I'm
sure like it really was traumatizing
that sort of like
torpedo of Internet Hate like I honestly
just don't know how like you can go back
to that for real
yet not even the Internet Hate but the
fact that like you lived without me in
your life like we were living together I
had to leave your house you know you've
been doing all these things the last few
years I haven't been a part of you had a
child and then how you just kind of like
not jump back into things but
resume a friendship with all of that
kind of looming I don't know how I'm
sure they've worked through it and that
those things aren't an issue but that
takes actually a lot of emotional work
yeah and now uh people did notice uh on
Tick Tock that Jordan Woods had reposted
a video that was like a joke about how
whenever you're watching the Kardashians
and Kendall comes on screen you press
fast forward
she had reposted it
that's which is so funny because if
she's gonna like dislike anyone I
wouldn't imagine it's Kendall
you never know it's also entirely
possible like it was an accident I mean
it's very hard to repost a video on
accident you have to press like four
buttons yeah
no I don't think it was an accident we
need to I know it would be easier for
everyone just like Scientology
blackmailed them for us to say oh
accident but I think there's a lot of
Dynamics at play here I completely agree
just an interesting thing to note while
she's been out and about with kyleena
yeah
but she's also like not wrong
no she's not wrong because you know
health is really important too Kendall
right right and that doesn't always make
the most compelling TV no and it doesn't
have to it does not have to not everyone
needs to be making the most compelling
TV she's making compelling photo shoots
I don't fast forward through those you
don't I don't fast forward through her
Instagram photos they're very nice yeah
yeah I could be good at everything not
everything can be everyone can be
everything to everyone all at once
everywhere exactly are you ready for our
next story if it's our next story that's
brought to you by Pillsbury whoa yeah
yum I mean yummy I'm an extremely picky
eater I feel like we have a lot of
listeners who have children they cook
for who probably have the same level of
palette as me who has hours to make
dinner every single night so Pillsbury
crescent rolls are fabulous if you want
to add them into your weeknight dinner
rotation they have so many simple
recipes doing the most but not actually
so they won't take long making fillings
for Pillsbury crescent rolls with
delicious ingredients that will
transform the crescents from a side dish
to a main dish with Pillsbury Pillsbury
crescents it's as easy as fill roll bake
to please your picky eaters and move on
with your evenings so weeknight recipes
can be tough you know we got a lot of
things going on
chores homework whatever it is and you
just don't have six hours to put
together a five-star meal but with
Pillsbury crescents you don't need it
it's as easy as fill roll and bake roll
up your favorite ingredients into a
crescent roll you know you can make a
nice little pizza a little sauce a
little cheese a little crescent roll
that's gorgeous maybe a pepperoni if
you're not a Jewish Queen they're quick
and easy spin for a weeknight recipe
they have fabulous recipes at
pillsbury.com like I said the pizza
crescent rolls chicken bacon ranch
crescent rolls ham and cheese crescent
rolls you can find Pillsbury in the
dairy aisle and it's dinner prep in 30
minutes or less it's pleasing for the
picky eater so check it out with my
dinners need not be a whole Orchestra
you know no and that sounds Gourmet I
know today's episode is also brought to
you by hatch the restore two wait that's
so crazy because I just got a text from
Zach asking him he asked me to turn the
sound machine on my hatch and that's
what I was just doing on my phone no lie
was turning on the sound machine in the
bedroom as we get older our
responsibilities and challenges increase
causing stress levels to rise but
prioritizing quality sleep is one of the
best way to take care of yourself
instead of lingering on your phone
before bed make sleep your simplest
self-care routine with the hatch restore
too I'm on like month six of my hatch I
was saying how I was looking for like
low lift
Wellness activities and everybody
recommended the hatch as a better way to
wake up it is I love it and all the you
know bells and whistles like the sound
machine are fabulous like really the
light I love like reading with my light
it's the best it's the best the wake up
is so Humane it's a very humane way to
wake up I actually had an unlocked on my
hatch potential until I got back to
Florida last week and I saw all of this
sap the noise options like you can have
white noise pink noise Brown noise I
like to sleep now with a little rainfall
it's been great for Charlie
experimenting with all of these noises
and plus all like the awake content they
have meditation think of the hatch
restore too as your bedside sleep guide
your Ally and rest the Innovative
all-in-one dream machine is a
sophisticated sound machine light and
alarm clock it's beautifully designed
for your bedside table good rest allows
you to be the best version of yourself
which is why the hatch restored 2 was
engineered to help you form healthy
sleep habits for Life your touch teaches
your body when it's time to sleep and
when it's time to rise with light and
sound cues it coaches you through
meditations and mindfulness exercise
that transform the time before and after
sleep into restful rituals right now
hatchet's offering our listeners 20 off
your first purchase of a hatch restore
too and free shipping at hatch dot Co
slash toast sleep deeply and wake gently
with the restore too go to hatch.co
toast to get 20 off and free shipping
that's hatch dot Co slash toast oh
amazing discount and six things no I
know our next story Chris Evans marries
Alba Batista in a Cape Cod wedding with
superhero co-stars as guests and hearts
are breaking around the globe Hearts
breaking everywhere Chris Evans is
married the actor wed Alba Batista
during a ceremony at a private estate in
Cape Cod Massachusetts on Saturday A
source told people many of the couple's
famous friends were spotted in nearby
Boston for the wedding including his
co-stars Robert Downey Jr and his wife
Chris Hemsworth and his wife and Jeremy
Renner John Krasinski and Emily Blunt
yeah apparently like Boston was crawling
with celebs all weekend on their way to
Cape Cod
um now Alba Batista is a normie correct
I believe so I cannot think of her and
whenever I see a picture of them I'm
like this is a romance novel like it's
not real
he is a romance novel and he's like
fat hero what are they called leading
man yeah but like for the entirety of
his career like he has been the most
eligible bachelor like everyone is
obsessed with him he literally plays
Captain America right yeah like the
biggest superhero in the world like Nev
like everyone's just obsessed with him
and he finds like this really beautiful
you know girl you know it's a simple
life she comes from a simple normal
background it's literally like a Tessa
Bailey novel it's not real
yes also she's not a normie she's an
actress who starred in Mrs Harris goes
to Paris I love that book Netflix is
Warrior none oh look you know what I'm
glad that she's like industry in like
you know in the industry
can be and I liked the story better like
when she was in Norway it was like more
of a fairy tale that I would read in a
book I liked it better
um but it makes more sense like I would
enormy even meet Chris Evans no but I
could see him being into normies but
he's also just like I
I don't know
I I feel like this will be a successful
match I do too because he's not like
he's not a Serial dater yeah I've always
gotten the vibe that he like wants to
find the right girl and I feel like the
only relationship he's been in that I
know about is he was with Jenny slate
for many many years so he's clearly like
a relationship guy yeah
it's nice I like wish she was ignoring
me that like kind of ruined the fantasy
for me
well
there's always Jonah Hill
there's always Jonah Hill literally yeah
literally I'm sure he was on the phone
with Mila and Ashton this weekend
Jonah yeah what all calling in from a
bunker of canceled people oh yeah yeah
yeah people go comparatively
comparatively Jonah Hill like is nothing
really you think oh yeah
see this you could always it could
always be worse it's true you could
always be made on Ashen for today until
it's the next person it's so true
but I feel like this might be like just
the beginning of like a slew of of bad
weeks for Mila and Ashton honestly
because of like these old videos and
stuff yeah and this is just like it's so
serious you know yes like the Jonah Hill
thing like I don't know it was just I
feel like you could chalk it up to like
Instagram drama like well I feel like
actually it's a little dip it could say
you could actually make the argument
that one is worse than the other because
like in the meal and Ash in case it's
like they didn't do anything right they
didn't do any bad behavior I don't know
what the internet's gonna dig up but the
case you know they just are supporting
their friend who did whereas with Jonah
yes it's not like serious crimes alleged
but it was his behavior yeah no that's
actually a good point so I'm sure
they're going back and forth in the
bunker about who has it works yeah right
right right
oh that's funny
anyways Mazel Tov to Chris Evans yes
very very nice very happy but you know
what a Cape Cod wedding really is like a
romance novel it's giving Ellen Hill the
brand Jerry I'm telling you like
when I just see a picture of them she's
so she really is so normal looking she's
like this beautiful simple girl who like
doesn't wear a lot of makeup because
she's naturally beautiful I know but but
now that you know she's an actress it's
like oh no she did have her makeup done
and that's like the look yeah no it's
definitely the fantasy is over well I
think you should buy the romance novel
that's fan fiction like based on these
two what you thought about them
no I'm kind of obsessed write it girl
writer girl writer girl write it girl
comma writer girl
Exclamation point Exclamation point yes
girly
[Laughter]
let's move on
girly let's move on to our next story is
this fourth or fifth fourth okay Joe
Jonas is addressing the messy divorce
rumors from Sophie Turner they performed
in La at Dodger Stadium on Saturday
night and Joe took to the mic said it's
been a crazy week I just want to say
look if you don't hear it from these
lips don't believe it okay
he said thank you everyone for your love
and support me and my family love you
guys then they sang hesitate
oh that's the song he wrote about Sophie
so it was like a very intentional timing
for a little speech
um I just want to say I feel like this
fixes nothing this helps nobody no I
think it I I think there's been a major
turn in public perception and that's why
I don't think he would have said
anything if like the narrative had
continued to go his way so
reading between the lines of what he
said and from sort of like my
spectator's point of view not like
Tick-Tock memes yes Twitter it's like
when they announce the divorce there was
some shady language about Sophie because
the kids are with Joe and Joe's on a
world tour and why is that and he just
leaves one to wonder what's going on
with Sophie
um
and so then people started to say like
well Joe's planting these like nasty
things about Sophie and people didn't
like that very misogynist that like why
not the camera footage the ring camera
why shouldn't the kids be with their
father it wouldn't be literally if they
were with their mother no and it's like
there's Paparazzi of him having lunch
with his kids and they're like oh my god
you're kidding to eat it like right
right and if there was Paparazzi of them
having lunch with Sophie it wouldn't be
news crazy but it's like they're still
with their parent right so then people
you know thought that Joe was planting
those things probably to make Sophie
look bad and now they're all want to
defend Sophie against like these
allegations and so he's definitely
effect right so he's saying if I didn't
say it it wasn't said don't believe it
so he wants us to believe that all the
things that came out really negative at
Sophie had nothing to do with him
yeah pretty much and that it's not
necessarily true if he didn't say it and
he didn't say it
I don't know
yeah I'm definitely a part of the people
who like it's had a negative effect on
like
when all these things started to come
out I'm like this is a little too
convenient you know it takes two people
to break up a marriage it really does
yeah well then also then it came out
someone some Source had said that Joe
wasn't there for Sophie when she like
struggled after her second child so
there's kind of very I don't even want
to say like mud thingy because it's so
subliminal you know and it's like source
source source and it's just like ring
camera not even what was was it said or
was it done they didn't even know or
they didn't even say so it's like
they're just planting these really tiny
seeds that are on the one hand so vague
it could be innocuous but on the other
hand then your mind starts to wander
what did he see on the ring coming you
think of the worst possible thing like
cheating yeah or her like saying
something you know so mean about him
yeah I've seen some funny tweets I know
people are being funny and I'm enjoying
it yeah no we have to be able to laugh
through the pain we're all of course
this is painful for all of us we're more
like the loss of a great celebrity
couple but I think we just need to pull
back from this and be like you know
there's definitely any wrong do or you
know both parties are hurt
you never want to see a divorce happen
now they're starting like to sort of say
some mean stuff about each other but
let's not listen how about that okay
okay you know I just I think maybe he
thought this speech would like call off
the dogs a little bit and I feel it's
very non-impactful but he also needs to
call off his dogs who are planting yes
these sorts of things in addition to
calling off people who are like
you know saying mean things about him
too yeah I just think it's it's hard and
all of these different factors don't
make it any easier
yes I agree and I also think like for
him to be going through such a public
divorce that was like really nobody saw
coming and to have to get on stage every
night and seeing timing for other people
like that must be really hard for him
I'm also sure given that this was
probably the last thing that he wanted
at this time you know what I mean
because even if he did one divorce I
doubt he wanted it when he's also gonna
go perform tonight the timing couldn't
be worse even though I think one could
argue it makes the tour more interesting
yeah
but you have to be really like
diabolical to to care more about the
interest of your tour it's not like they
had a hard time selling tickets versus
how it will feel to go out every night
and you know what everybody's thinking
about you true true
so I'm gonna give them Grace
wow she's giving Grace what if we just
gave a little Grace it's giving Grace
that's me
it's you are you ready for our fifth and
final story if it's the final story
that's brought to you by State Farm it's
a State Farm personal price plan helps
you create a plan that gives you options
so you get an affordable price and it
comes with a lot of benefits like the
coverage you want a policy that helps
cover what's important to you and an
affordable price just for you because
after all life is just better when you
can personalize your experiences so
think about it like this what are your
music playlists podcast feeds and social
media Scrolls all have in common spoiler
alert they're a reflection of you we all
know my social media are full of
celebrity conspiracy theories these days
um I've ended up on Manjaro talk you
know it's very personal like me and
Jackie how similar are we but even our
feeds are different right my feeds are
all breastfeeding hacks right you know
how to how to burp your baby and that's
what the State Farm personal price plan
has in common too Jax it gives you
options to help you personalize your
coverage so you can protect what you
care about most at an affordable price
just for you so you can see more of
yourself in everything that you love
mm-hmm
like a good neighbor safe arm is there
call or go to statefarm.com today to
create your State Farm personal price
plan prices vary by state option
selected by customer availability and
eligibility may vary let me just try
that one more time like a good neighbor
Steve fireman's there call or go to
statefarm.com today to create your State
Farm personal price plan prices vary by
state options selected by customer
availability and eligibility may vary
thank you State Farm for sponsoring this
final story yes this final story Khloe
Kardashian Sports and necklace featuring
her kids names and including the name of
her niece dream so Chloe was on IG
stories doing an ad for fabletics what
caught people's eye in addition to the
garages threads was her necklace that
saves her kids names uh what's that one
Tatum true dream I just want to say like
this is
unintentionally like the best most
amazing money fabletics has ever spent
right like on for your for some of your
Instagram content to go viral and it's
an ad oh my God that's clicks you can't
even pay for yes for sure dream
dream Kardashian dream so everyone
noticed immediately like it's not it's
not uncommon to have a necklace with
your kid's name on it I know you wear a
hairy necklace I'm sure you'll have a
Charlie one soon like it's not uncommon
but dream especially after like this
most recent season of Kardashians she
had to actually have to release a
statement saying like she doesn't see
herself as you know dreams mother but
she's clearly very involved very invited
and what she said on Kardashians was
that she feels like you know a third
parent yeah and even though that didn't
play well with audiences that doesn't
change the reality of their day-to-day
and we don't know what that is but if
dream is
with her almost as much as her kids are
and she's wearing a necklace that just
say Tatum and true
you know that could be hurtful to dream
and so I think at the end of the day
it's just about like what stream seeing
on this woman that she spends all of her
time with who treats her like a child
her own child you know in a wonderful
way I don't think Chloe's trying to
usurp China in any way and I do think
that if she was so concerned about what
people thought about it she would have
tucked her necklace in so like I think
that this necklace is just a
representation of the reality of their
lives yeah I mean what we don't know
much about like Rob's situation but we
do know that he has primary custody I
think it's one day a week or maybe two
that China has custody and Rob and Chloe
are so close I'm sure every day he has
dream he just goes over to the house and
they all hang out together so it in a
weird way looks like a very you know
typical family yeah
um so you're right actually that's an
amazing point that like if they're all
hanging out all the time and you know
dreams learning to read and she sees a
necklace and it's like where am I
yeah no it's true it's at the end of the
day it's sweet but there's definitely a
complicated Dynamic with
China definitely and I just want to say
I love the necklace and they want one so
if she could drop the link it's really
cute if the necklace company could do an
ad drop a link
um I had read a few weeks ago because
you know China's on this like journey of
redemption China's found God China has
found God she removed a lot of her
filler she's dressing more
conservatively she's kind of turning
into like a kept woman
um actually I don't know it's kept women
the right word because she's a business
owner that's not what I meant I meant
like a traditionalist if you will and I
had read that she was going to begin the
process of um
fighting for more custody okay well it
seems like she's in a good place now I
hope that that is how this story ends
because when you watch like Kardashians
and how they're like you know dream is
such a big part of their lives and then
you also look at China's social media
and it's really like she is trying
really to better to better herself I do
hope that means that these two parties
can come together the elephant in the
room is the 100 million dollar lawsuit
and it's like how do you get it how do
you get past that I really don't know
oh that's an amazing question I totally
had forgotten about that I would love to
you know think of a future where we can
get to a place where like they really do
get past it in China ultimately like
feels enormous gratitude to Chloe for
helping out when China was struggling
um I don't know if we'll ever get to a
place like that right but it's like
China and Kim used to be really good
friends I know so it's not and it's so
crazy like when you think back on Robin
China when you think back on Kylie and
Tyga and China when you think back on
the picture that they took in front of
the mirror like it was really not a
normal time no it's crazy and you and
you like to think that maybe they could
get back to that place considering like
they were friends they they get along
they did but the lawsuit throws a wrench
into things so I don't know
how that would go but I think it's
possible also the Kardashians are very
forgiving yeah either Women of Faith
yeah and a Chloe is very free like she
doesn't hold on to stuff I mean she's
forgiving Tristan obviously right
I think this would be the biggest thing
they would have to forgive you know all
the Chinese stuff but I think that they
wouldn't could do it if she was if she
were genuinely sorry the only reason
that they could is because one thing
about them the only thing like the thing
that always comes first is the kids yeah
and they would put aside personal
grievances for dream and that's just the
kind of people that they are like for
real yeah but this would be the biggest
thing they I think that they've had to
forgive
yeah
that was like remember like Chris like
they really tried to make it work like
they gave her their own show they were
living in that house like they tried to
make it nice and it didn't work out that
was so crazy it was crazy but none of
that is as crazy as the lawsuit no yeah
the time the energy the days the stress
like the money going to court I honestly
I don't know if it's forgivable
and also is China sorry does China take
it back this is the Forgiveness just
yeah is China asking for forgiveness I
don't know these are Big questions does
China really think like okay you know
what I was wrong you guys didn't you
weren't the reason that you took my show
away
yeah
without that there's no conversation to
be had
yeah no it's a good question like is she
she even playing ball like is this a
fruitless conversation is she asking for
gift right right right
well I think the necklace is sweet I'm
sure some people see it as weird I think
the necklace is so sweet and indicative
of their reality and in which case you
know Chloe's a wonderful woman
I mean Chloe I think time after time has
really shown like she has endless love
to give she has an enormous heart she's
like a deeply good person yeah
and I want that necklace so it's sweet
like I'm gonna try like I'm not gonna
make it weird
yeah is it diamonds I can't see it looks
just like silver to me Jackie's fixated
on the necklace
yeah like troubling thanks girl I feel
like I'm sure whoever made it will be
you know posting about it in no time
capitalizing on the momentum hopefully a
toaster to let us know where we can shop
it maybe it's fabletics maybe they're
going into jewelry maybe it's a Tob a
toaster own business
I would love that love a Tob those were
great stories like really compelling
stuff this week yeah but it's also just
because it's like me and you doing our
thing so true oh my God I miss you so
much girlfriend well what's exciting is
that you're on twice this week I am on
twice this week on Friday not only am I
on but we'll be together in Florida yes
Flamingo style so we've got a great week
we posted a schedule on our Instagram
today we got Jax tomorrow we got Taylor
strecker Wednesday we've got Hannah
burner Thursday we've got a major
celebrity coming in Ben Soffer and
Friday back with Jax good way to start
in the week you know our original recipe
it's like it's giving palindrome
it's giving bookends
it's giving bookends because it's not a
true palindrome unless BSC was doing
Tuesday and Thursday and no it's not a
palindrome
not me not realizing like what a
palindrome was until you just said that
you know who loves the palindrome
race car
young Sheldon
he does
um all right well that's our show Jax
thank you for your time thank you for
your company and thank you for all the
other shows that you are gracing us with
enjoy motherhood
thank you enjoy antihood I will as will
I
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the money Morning Show where
we deliver the past five stories so you
need to know everybody through Friday on
YouTube oh I wanted to address something
Stitcher has gone out of business
well that's not funny sorry it's just
funny that that's what you need to
address yeah no I like kind of the
elephant in the room and I do I think a
lot of people were waiting to be like
what will she do I will I will not be
updating the I think half the platforms
I say are out of business
but it's just kind of like not my
problem you know and also like it's part
of the Zeitgeist at this point it's not
about the platforms like we know you're
all listening on Apple or Spotify yeah
and I'm like I'm sorry that a billion
dollar company like SiriusXM couldn't
keep Stitch or afloat like that's I
don't see how that becomes my problem
and I have to shift and evolve and you
have to change your ways so having said
that thank you so much for listening to
the toaster
unclear I Heart Radio never heard of her
just on YouTube please don't forget to
subscribe give this video a thumbs up
we're also available anywhere podcasting
events at Spotify iTunes District public
radio I have reading Castro's all the
places trying to listen to the podcast
Finance the Joseph standing in wickedly
talented we are I haven't really thought
about all the places do you say public
radio at some point yeah that like was
an app like I I think it's still it's
like you can really listen to podcasts
on like a lot of different apps if you
Google the toast podcast like there's
endless Links of where you could listen
to play Oh No but like stuff like
literally let me do it it's yeah
but I just want to say like I'm not
changing my outro I don't want you to
okay good because I'm not
the toast podcast
Spotify
Amazon music hmm
pod tail
what
I heart pod chaser
pod Bean
that sort of podbean my point proven
yeah
great and my point that I'm not changing
anything is also proven okay it's
because you know what I'm a creature of
habit it's and that's it's folklore
it's a folklore and it's like if I'm
expected to shift my outro every time
some podcast app flops there'll be no
end of it no we just can't be beholden
to the tides of the industry
we can't be beholden to the tides of the
industry that's what I'm saying
so have a great day everyone love you
bye love you bye